welcome to this video playing black
against p ed denmark yep Sicilian oh
this is so gay I've four games against
him in 10 form that's nice I would have
many opponents like that way you have
won all games ok let's see the rosula
Moses I am naive 5 here has played very
early hmm no can do that of course not
another deadline probably some kind of
transposition when he the castles now is
not castling Wow let's start a move that
comes to mind that easily okay if I go
to f4 something is deform idea probably
to c7 ok that's somewhat surprising
don't really know by white one c4 in the
structure beginning d 4 D 3 ok so he
wants to play king it we are on how we
see not losing the deep hole ok night to
d6 and I to e6 I mean and yeah probably
a funny position here so what am i doing
just 27 and piling up on this on the d3
pawn right playing normal stuff you see
able to play that's a queen bee three
rookie won just about to keep this
protected it probably has to do
something like that oh ok ok that's it
surprising I give this check every
Bishop age 5 and to push all the pawns
on I can also just go to g6 which isn't
bad let's do that come on keep it simple
Bishop g4 also was interesting just
provoke him to play all those come on
all those weakening moves ok on when
Quincy 7 is not exactly bad quince is 79
how does he protect a 5 ok yeah with
that move ok g5
yeah takes Queen takes looks horrible
and f5 night f4 it's not looking any
better
so f4 or deform both interesting I guess
he writes I'm not clear both both
looking good yeah maybe yes to do
something like 6am just trying to muddy
the waters otherwise I just play Queen
e5 castle long and I'm like one or two
pawns up and have the dominating
position so check let's go with this
King f1 the question is how do I and now
I can win the look right or not Quincy
to just just one moment here I can one
can okay this is just the rook right
cakes or is he is he trapping my queen
look see one or something as may be
possible
yeah maybe I shouldn't have done that
now that I look at it because I'm not
straight away straightaway winning after
Queen a one can take f7 that's it's
still a bit unclear check him for rook
age 5 f-5 now I didn't play that the
best possible way absolutely not and I
over looked at it did he get this pawn I
am such an idiot sometimes that this
game is still somehow going on it's just
so embarrassing oh wow that was really
really bad okay I couldn't be too what
what what what a bad idea i am what a
bad idea on g6 from a g6 amazing f what
kind of nonsense I sometimes come up
with him okay so I'm trying to get the
g6 pong
it's probably still very good for me but
that it was just like a complete win
yeah and the term that was just very
badly played check check okay so Bishop
e3 to the foyer that must be right ready
getting this or not Kruger just
attacking the part is also not bad maybe
you can go look h 12 h 7 now that i
think of it yeah probably
hmm
yeah I cannot calculate this now if this
how serious that is
maybe he people ultimately swindle
swindled out of that probably deservedly
it should have been over but when team
trying to play for for meeting attack
here with Ruby to end stuff maybe you
can can it takes you five four look see
one that I can keep the check if those
checks first alright study will have
Roxy one maybe mmm does this time time
spent now giving me okay so I check here
before check them time morning okay
check check check check
I just about catches the pond
Ruby 6 check check check check grah
offered dis a draw I don't know what is
this I cannot go King e5
yeah I cannot win this that's really
true grah offered bra fighter four feet
oh yeah yeah sorry I tried him yeah I
wanted to offer them a draw it was was
tricky at the end of just had one second
so sometimes it's a bit tricky yeah he
i'm not i cannot win of course why does
winning yeah with with the cupboard with
the past porn yeah I don't know I mean
it's so heartbreaking at this position
here I mean maybe I can really just take
the rook yeah my computer is on minus
eight I was I wasn't I wasn't talking
sure I thought maybe he can somehow
habit of course this is sometimes what
am I thinking here of course he cannot
play rook see what I just move the Queen
away and he cannot move the night and
sometimes what the heck you know I can
just take the rook and it's over check
yeah I don't know sometimes I mean one
thing that I definitely know what I
shouldn't play chess when I'm hungry and
I'm hungry at the moment maybe this is
really an issue having to low blood
sugars or something that you bet you
play totally totally nonsensical dad
yeah I mean this is just just know maybe
it's the better but it kind of it kind
of chat yeah it should have been over a
long time ago it really should yeah I
don't know b5 yeah here I'm winning
again but yeah the game should be over
in the in the opening the the
combination of moves here that white
played really was was very problematic
here after after that um Black is
definitely comfortable
and d3 I mean now you have to play very
very weird stuff maybe maybe Queen d7
long castles is even better at this is
very strong in any case he has huge
problems to keep keep his things
protected Quincy 7f form g5 is basically
a win I just have to take this plea rook
on a one I don't really know what I was
thinking there okay thanks for watching